and that black glass aluminum rails
massive specs quad cameras a hidden
stylus
oh wait wait hang on a sec yeah no that
was the wrong phone sorry let's start
that over
matte black glass aluminum rails massive
specs quad cameras a hidden stylus
you you get the point
hey what's up I'm Kim HD here and this
is the Samsung Galaxy s23 Ultra so when
this first came out when it got revealed
it was the easiest thing to do to just
write it off as a incremental upgrade
because I mean look at it like
aesthetically speaking it's basically
the same phone I mean the side radii are
squared off more so it feels a bit
better in the hand sure much more boxy
like the notes of the past they're also
slightly bigger rings around the cameras
and it's Gorilla Glass victus 2 instead
of victus plus but you know as far as
size industrial design button placement
ports the layout it's it's basically the
same phone but there are two real
upgrades to this phone now keep in mind
this is replacing the Galaxy s22 Ultra
which was already my best big phone of
the Year from last year great battery
great screen great performance all of it
was Rock Solid across the board so
there's not a lot that I would naturally
want to change but there are two things
and there are two of arguably the most
important things you can actually change
in a phone the chip that runs it all and
the cameras so you might have heard
about the Snapdragon 8 Gen 2 it's been a
really good chip in the other phones
that it's been in excellent CPU and GPU
performance and really efficient which
touches battery life now this phone
actually the whole s23 lineup has a
Snapdragon 8 Gen 2 for Galaxy a
customized version of the chip
specifically for these Samsung phones so
if you watch the last video about how
Apple's taking back the iPhone then you
know already that optimization and
customization for parts and side phones
is a good thing generally
but the only thing that we've really
seen that is customized for this chip
for Galaxy is a slightly higher Max
clock speed on the performance core and
slightly higher clock speed on the GPU
so to be exact uh 3.36 gigahertz instead
of 3.2 on the performance core and 719
megahertz versus 680 on the GPU so yeah
it does score slightly better on
benchmarks than the regular Snapdragon 8
Gen 2 and that's nice for a little extra
Headroom for high performance stuff
light gaming and for future proofing but
that's not the whole story there's two
main things that matter here one is
efficiency gains so obviously
performance is awesome but because
efficiency is better these phones get
some serious battery life gains that
we'll talk in a second but also too is
bye bye exynos because they're not
making an exynos version of this phone
as far as I can tell anywhere else
they're shipping every s23 Ultra with
the Qualcomm chip so everyone gets the
efficiency and performance gains from
the Qualcomm version so let me tell you
the battery life on this phone is
actually it's been incredible like it's
really really good so it's the 5 000
milliamp hour cell again shouldn't be a
surprise but with this huge screen I
guess it kind of is actually a surprise
I had a two day period at 120 hertz but
1080p where the only time I charged it
was on the wireless charger in my car on
the way to and from the studio for like
the 40 minutes that that drive is I
didn't charge it overnight or anything
like that two full packed days of high
brightness high intensity normal use for
me has something like eight and a half
hours of screen on time I'm in bed at
like 11 p.m at the end of the second day
streaming on YouTube live watching
LeBron break cream's record it's still
got like 10 percent left it just won't
die so combine this excellent battery
life with a pretty solid 45 watt
charging that can go zero to 100 in an
hour plus wireless charging and you've
got yourself a battery monster it's
super good I don't think enough people
are talking about how much better the
battery got maybe some will do one of
those crazy long runtime time demos
versus the past phone but yeah it's
really good probably better than you
think you kind of don't ever need to
switch to 1080p to save batteries so a
matter of fact when you take it out the
box immediately just go in and switch it
to 1440p
because you spent 1200 bucks on this
phone and it lasts forever treat
yourself
okay anyway that's the chips that's what
that enables but there's also a new set
of cameras hardware and software across
the board that also is better than you
think now the fundamentals are mostly
the same which is why this probably gets
written off so quickly a lot the layout
the Aesthetics the focal lengths the
arrangement it's all practically the
same but we have a new 200 megapixel
primary camera with double the optical
image stabilization range as before
that's hugely important and then new
sensors across the ultra wide the 3x
telephoto and the 10x Periscope cameras
this new primary sensor setup though I
know we keep saying cameras are mostly
software and as far as the look and
style of the photos it absolutely still
is but the Improvement to the
stabilization is so important here so
when you go from a normal sensor to a
super high resolution 200 megapixel
sensor the fact is in these tiny
smartphone cameras the individual pixels
are so small that individually they
physically can't bring in that much
light so the camera does this thing
called binning where it combines the
information from a bunch of adjacent
pixels to form larger more accurate
pixels in your image so you're not
shooting 200 megapixels by default it's
actually binning 16 pixels into one so
you end up taking a 12 and a half
megapixel shot for normal photos but
each photo is theoretically more
accurate thanks to its makeup and then
like I said the stabilization
performance on this new primary camera
has doubled
still rattles a little bit but that
means it'll correct up to three degrees
of shake Now versus the 1.5 from before
so here's kind of an example of what's
happening if you get a lens with really
good Optical image stabilization
like this one uh that means it can
correct from the movement in your hand
much more which means you can hold the
camera stable for much longer so it can
leave the shutter open to collect more
light and still get a sharp photo so all
this is to say Galaxy s23 Ultra photos
uh most of the time in most lighting
look pretty similar to last year so if
that's all you're looking at just like
normal side by sides this is mostly
going to come down to the different
software tuning and there's a little bit
more dynamic range than last year but
yeah still top of the line while mostly
avoiding looking too hdre photos are
typically pretty warm from these Samsung
phones and they have a slightly punchier
more contrasty look than before still
very much up the Samsung alley of like
colorful and saturated but it's an
aesthetic that I I can get behind I
really like but on top of that having
this new sensor and Optical
stabilization means one you can shoot
literally 200 megapixel photos now if
you really want to now this does
accomplish the intended purpose of
capturing much more of the finer detail
in things like landscape so if you plan
on zooming in on the shot later or if
you're one of the three people on Earth
who will actually print a smartphone
photo this should work but you should
also be aware that it's only really able
to give you these types of results in
excellent lighting where a ton of light
is hitting every individual little pixel
anything short of that and you're going
to get a lot of noise really quick and
there's also a really solid shutter lag
as it turns out these massive 40 50
megabyte files granted this mode is
mostly for things sitting still like a
landscape or a photo shoot but worth
noting I think the better compromises
you actually also get a 50 megapixel
mode which kicks out still very detailed
images that hang right with the iPhone's
48 megapixel Pro raw shots in a variety
of light but now the files are five
megabytes and there's a little less
shutter lag but there's still that
improved detail over the normal binge
shots and not as much noise it's all
about flexibility like the standard mode
is going to be the best for most shots
most of the time but but you can always
turn it up if you want to and that's
very much the same thing with the zoom
you see all the cameras on the back like
any phone with two different telephoto
cameras is going to have the biggest
range of good zoom performance on this
phone anything past 10x is where it
really shines compared to others and you
might have even seen my recent clip of
taking a photo of the full moon recently
which seems to blow people's minds every
time they see it wow but you also can't
forget about video too this is improved
video across the board with better
processing the new sensors and the much
better stabilization thanks to the
better ois so this might be the best
super study mode I've ever seen in
smartphone video and the beauty of it
being from Optical stabilization is it
works great in a variety of lighting
unlike you know some electronic image
stabilization which relies on having a
ton of light and on top of all of that
the 8K video on the smartphone is very
usable there are previous phones that
have had 8K video it's not the first but
I remember when they first got that
capability they'd always be at like 24
FPS because that's the most that they
could churn out which
is not the right frame rate so ak-30
really good and if you put it side by
side with the 4K you can actually see
the sharpness difference if you really
punch in if you want a sample of this
the latest autofocus video I shot in my
car is in 8k from this phone and you can
actually go watch it 8K on YouTube right
now from the link below that like button
if you want to
oh yeah and also don't forget about the
better selfies too there's a new 12
megapixel selfie camera and all these
s23 phones and while that number is
lower on paper than the 40 megapixel
selfie camera that came before it uh
it's better it's just better Rock Solid
proof that the megapixels don't matter
this selfie camera with the better
software processing is very sharp
detailed has nice color doesn't flare
too much and also has a decently wide
angle it's not Ultra wide but not bad so
across the board this is significant an
extensive Improvement to the camera
especially the primary camera that's
feels overlooked to me when people have
been reviewing this phone uh the one
thing I still will complain about is
there is still shutter lag which is
different from slow shutter speed so
like the time gap between hitting the
shutter button and actually capturing
the photo it's still real and it can
still be kind of annoying even if you
capture a crisp photo of the wrong
moment so like I said it's more
pronounced when you take the ultra high
resolution 50 megapixel or 200 megapixel
photos you can't exactly do those in
Rapid Fire but if the question is did
they make a meaningful Improvement to
last year's phone to end up here I would
say between the new chip and the better
overall performance and much better
efficiency which gets you huge battery
life Improvement and the new cameras
with the better sensors better
processing but also much better
stabilization
I would say yes not upgrade from last
year's phone yes but they've actually
made a real Improvement and then I don't
really need to say too much about the
rest because it's the same as before
which in the case of the best big phone
of last year is kind of a good thing
like all the other things that made this
the best big phone are still here and
they're not minor things either I
haven't even talked about the a plus
display 1440p 120 hertz ltpo 1750 nits
Peak brightness it's still awesome still
has great speakers still has very
reliable software with a pretty good
track record now of delivering software
updates in a timely fashion for a while
the base storage has also actually
jumped up from 128 to 256 gigs and it's
faster ufs 4.0 storage now it still has
the best stylus and a smartphone in the
world which might mean a lot more to you
than it does to me but you know honestly
if I ever use it it's nice knowing I can
at any time mark up a screenshot or sign
a PDF and the list goes on great haptic
motor nice clicky buttons it's all still
here this thing sets the standard pretty
high my analogy that I was making is it
it feels like the Porsche 911 of
smartphones like if you're gonna charge
1200 bucks for a phone it better set
High marks all the way across the board
but it does and it's pretty underrated
kind of boring but it does now if you
want the s23 ultra to look as improved
as it actually is I would recommend a
skin from Channel sponsor dbrand maybe
something like this Damascus skin which
adds a lot of character where it would
ordinarily be pretty blank you know my
favorite one is a triple black it is
actually included for free when you pick
up like any of the holographic colorways
so you can check them out at the link
below like I say this phone is boring
and I think maybe understated is the
better word like are there going to be
other phones that come out this year
that do one-up this phone in certain
single categories yeah 100 like there's
probably going to be a phone with 120x
zoom there's probably going to be a
phone with I mean crazy fast charging
this is only 45 watt charging do I wish
this was better a little bit sometimes
is there going to be a phone probably
with a much bigger better faster
fingerprint reader yeah probably
but as far as just like nailing all the
marks across the board yeah this does it
just as far as overall package Samsung's
software is settled the screen is
Sublime it's still the sickest stylus
and it snaps significantly smoother
shots
sick
thanks for watching catch you guys in
the next one peace
[Music]